I was just getting to learn Quentin
Tarantino so he was again a tyrant you
know he was he was at this do not [ __ ]
my film Chiron in the sense that is he
insists on every word being just the way
he wrote it that's what you want you
want you want you want a director who
even if you're going off the cliff you
know that you're going off the [ __ ]
cliff don't you want the freedom to also
kind of admire now ya know the first day
of rehearsal I'm reading my lines I did
it did it did cut but then Nesbitt and
he said cut can I talk to you for a
second
who's going Oh what the [ __ ] is that
mean I knew I was gonna have this
problem listen all of this [ __ ] you have
to be a [ __ ] slave okay he's a slave
he's not cool he's a [ __ ] slave right
he doesn't know how to read you come in
with your [ __ ] Louie bag and your
[ __ ] Range Rover and your [ __ ]
gesso I'm so [ __ ] you're not Jim
Brown he's a [ __ ] slave and then and
then he becomes the hero but lose that
[ __ ] door swings open he walks up Wow
would you work with Quentin Tarantino
generation just to God a long time oh
you would